I'm in Brixton prison trying to make a
success out of my bad boys bakery
My Kitchen team have complained they're
getting grief from the officers but the
officers themselves have got a different
version of events they're superstars
calling me all names and the Sun
[ __ ] and God knows what yeah I'm
finding incredibly frustrating getting a
prison kitchen up and running and I'm
not in the mood for any bat chat and the
officers aren't the only ones giving me
a hard time
Yeah right you know the procedure really
if there's trust they can leave it open
do not I mean taste the piss
what I need are team players convicted
burglar Renny Smith is a good cook but
sometimes he's more interested in
cleaning up that's how I am I see so I'm
just naturally like I don't know if I've
got always CC or whatever they've
already called it
that's my upbringing you make sure you
got clean boxes every day one and number
two you make sure you make your bed OCD
or not Rene can be a real handful
it's not his first time inside but I'll
never come back to this place never I
hate him
the sunroof world is
all of you come over let's go Kiev's
done I need to check everyone's
handiwork lots of parsley very good do
you taste the butter no whose is this
one no that's all that waterfall he
didn't put the water on the cows on
there did you ready cheers for that let
me finish my [ __ ] job look at me
you're trying to be funny
no choice for that the last thing I need
today is Reni busting my balls about a
bit of cooking juice on a tidy work
surface but when I'm in the middle of a
conversation and you rudely interrupt me
and say cheers' Pat gordon like you own
the [ __ ] stove do you own it don't
talk like you only then I'm getting sick
and tired of all this petty [ __ ] you
guys like the growing man you have an
amazing opportunity here knuckle down
and do something and if you don't want
to do that then go back to yourself
Renee has taken me at my word and warp
this team that pull that [ __ ] shut up
there are things with four bits
I mean they all love it y'all ain't
gonna get nowhere and Johnny's got to
keep us on our toes because you know
what we [ __ ] prisoners we are going to
cut corners here and there so I mean
what your s what we're that's what we
know it's hard very very hard I've been
holding back
since I got in here I mean really
holding back so how many times they need
to cross you before you you're gonna go
for it
and so yeah yes there's areas I'm
struggling
with a pressure I'm under
I've overreacted I don't want to lose a
good cook like Renee serve ask for a
sit-down exactly how are you yeah yeah
quick two minutes yeah that's why I tell
you something really important yeah okay
you're in prison yeah I'm in prison to
do a job right yeah and yeah I snapped
but here's what I want to say when you
work and you put that effort in you
shine I think it might have come out
wrong which I put my hands up to that as
I said you know what Cora
I'm sorry ain't it I know I can say it
and you know I'm not closing the door
understand don't throw away no all I can
say good I'm sorry I'm so so for you
wasting your time for coming over here
I'll see you Monday morning appreciate
and I'll catch up on my work Monday
morning appreciate ya thank you Hey
in future whatever the reason I can't
allow any kind of dissent from my team
from now on anyone that walks out stays
out